Hello, Vsauce. Michael here,
and today I have a brand new episode
of Vsauce Leanback, a playlist that I host
made out of awesome videos from
all over YouTube.
The theme for this one is stuff
I didn't know last week, but now I do.
It's fun and you can begin at anytime by
clicking the link at the top
of this video's description. If you're on a
mobile device, it probably won't work,
so wait until you're at a computer and
then you can lean back.
In the meantime I'm gonna give you one
cool fact and four things you can do
online now guys.
Alright, first the fact.
America and Europe are on
different tectonic plates and these plates
are slowly moving apart from each other,
which means that every year America and Europe
are 1 inch further apart.
You know what else grows
at one inch a year?
Fingernails.
What's cool about that is that,
for instance if you live in America,
every time you look at your fingernails
you can think "hmmm, since the last time I
clipped these,
Europe is that much farther away."
Pretty neat.
If you enjoy deep emotional flash games,
"veronica1095" sent me a list
of some really cool ones.
But if you prefer making your own music,
check out Qwerty Beats.
All you need to be a DJ is your mouse
and your keyboard.
If you want your mind blown by
perspective, play Adult Swim's Cardboard
Box
Assembler. This game is laid out on a
three-dimensional cube
and as you run around you can change what's up
and what's down. And finally, if you're one
of those people who hate Vsauce
Leanbacks because they're so long,
go check out 5secondfilms.
It's a YouTube channel
with 775 hilarious videos,
so short they're only five seconds long. And what the
H, here's a bonus.
This guy is counting to 1 billion
on YouTube.
One number at a time, one video
for each number. He's only up to about
200 right now, but let me give you a taste.
Here's a good one. 23.
Twenty-three.
Nice. So, what are you waiting for?
Click the link at the top of this video's
description to begin the new episode
of Vsauce
Leanback.
And as always,
thanks for watching.